on select Sleep Number
360 smart beds. Only for a
limited time.
Download now and get
♪ ♪
>> Bret: YOU KNOW AMERICANS
ARE STOCKING UP ON BREAD AND
WATER AND TOILET PAPER, BUT
TONIGHT WE’LL TELL YOU WHAT ELSE
YOUR FELLOW CITIZENS ARE BUYING
IN BIG NUMBERS.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE SHOWS US
FROM LOS ANGELES.
>> FROM NEW YORK TO CALIFORNIA.
>> WITH EVERYTHING RAPIDLY
DECLINING, IT’S NOW OR NEVER.
>> MAYBE I WON’T BE ABLE TO GET
IT TOMORROW, A LITTLE BIT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
>> GUN SALES AROUND THE U.S.
SHOOTING SKY HIGH.
>> THEY DON’T CARE, THEY WANT
SOMETHING.
THEY DON’T CARE WHAT IT IS, IT
DOESN’T MATTER, JUST GIVE ME
SOMETHING.
>> THE FBI SAYS BACKGROUND
CHECKS SURGED TO A NEAR RECORD
OF 3 MILLION IN FEBRUARY.
>> I’M AFRAID OF WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN IF THEY GO INTO MARTIAL
LAW, THEY CAN’T GET TO THE
MARKETS OR HAVE FOOD.
THEY ARE GOING TO RESORT TO
LOSING PEOPLE’S HOUSES.
>> EVERYONE IS SCARED AND THEY
ARE UNCERTAIN.
WHAT YOU’RE GOING TO EXPERIENCE
IS PEOPLE PREPARING THEMSELVES.
IT’S NOT VIGILANTES, ITS PEOPLE
CONCERNED ABOUT PROTECTING THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> AMMUNITION IS IN SHORT
SUPPLY.
>> AMMO IS RIDICULOUS, WE GOT IN
AN ORDER OF 6,009-MILLIMETER,
THEY ARE ALREADY GONE.
>> 90% ARE NEW BUYERS INCLUDING
ASIAN-AMERICANS.
>> I ENCOUNTER PEOPLE WHO TELL
ME TO STAY INSIDE, WASH MY
HANDS, GET OUT OF HERE.
>> THESE PANIC GUN SALES AREN’T
GOING TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
FOR ANYBODY.
>> LAW ENFORCEMENT FEARS NEW
BUYERS MEANS NEW ACCIDENTS.
>> IF YOU HAVE ONE SECURED
SAFELY, IT’S INACCESSIBLE.
>> NINE OTHER STATES REQUIRE A
WAITING PERIOD OF THREE TO TEN
DAYS.
FOR THESE PEOPLE CONCERNED ABOUT